[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey
[Music]
[Applause]
hey babe sorry i have watermelon stuck
in my throat watermelon
46 calories for a whole cup that's
unbelievable you blew my mind with that
one
yes yeah because i'm thinking high sugar
i know it's mostly water-based
yes but a cup of of basically a treat a
sweet treat at 46 calories
where can you go wrong where can you go
wrong i haven't physically
been in your presence in three months i
know a lot of the fans
this is we're back way back
they thought i was flying back every
week just to do hey babe they said how
are you in california on wednesday night
and in the studio thursday at 8 a.m
unbelievable
in new york i said let's you know i i
don't know that a couple times yeah
i said spirit airlines treats me nice um
i just by the way you've been gone
obviously you're golden you're bronzed
you see it's one of those things i've
been in l.a so long that yeah it might
your skin just starts to because i'm i'm
not a sun guy i'm not a beach guy
no but i ju but you came in that's the
first thing you said you said oh your
skin changed
yeah yeah yeah because you have you
don't have uh you just got a tan
no you have you've settled into a tan
yes
you've been living right out west for
months
and now you have the layers you you're
you're basically la
la sun kissed like crazy now yeah i've
i've i've turned into a puerto rican
yeah which has always been my dream
look at look at me i look like i i
honestly look like i have a iron
deficiency
yes yeah you look like you have scurvy
yeah yeah
you come in you got bright your color
palette has changed everything she's got
turquoise i mean you're very easy breezy
easy breezy beautiful cover girl girl
i just had um a speaking of tans you
ready for this
just this morning you know i do my
podcast to chrissy chaos of course
you're from my actual house am i
actually living where my family lives i
had a man on the show named john a light
john gotti's henchman john gotti's uh
one of his top hit men was telling me
what my daughter feet away
that he's killed 21 people and would
would quite often shoot people in the
head and then have a cheeseburger in the
pudding
and i asked him if he'd like a coffee
from my keurig machine that's it you let
him right into the house
right to the house and and was he there
for the lord
how do you settle into a conversation
with a man like that how many years
reformed is he when was his last kill
he he we didn't ask him when his la his
last kill had to be if i had to guess
i don't think he killed anyone after 9
11. because it was just a lie
it would be disrespectful it would be
disrespectful he's told us many times
he's a proud patriot
so i don't know that he would unless you
know he was fighting in the war now here
he is
this is were talking the man older guy
no well this guy looks like like like i
i was not expecting this person no why
is every
outfit a picture of him out in that
outfit oh well i think that's that's he
was that's when he was handcuffed i
think he was going
to jail um um yeah he was going to
jail these are jail photos all right
when he's walking into this
man killed 21 people more more maybe
more i
i don't know he's killed quite a lot of
people um
and he's actually fully albanian he's
not italian but
he was the hitman for the mob um shot
between 30 to 40 people
beat about 100 people with a baseball
bat and killed six people okay
later in life eli publicly denounced the
life of organized crime and became a
motivational speaker and a writer so
he's a motivational speaker i bet he
did yeah i mean what else choice do you
have you have to at some point
denouncement has to come
you have to you can't just not denounce
yeah you you shot
40 people killed six and b that many
people
at one point you gotta be like guys not
for me well here's what here's what's
interesting and i think we're gonna do
this for the fans on hey babe and i
think it's i think it's some
i think it's something we'll do for the
patreon oh you got uh yes i mean
i johnny like that if you go to john
daylight.com i just screw my balls back
from the last time you were here and now
they're blown clear off
so what we're going to tell you what i
want to tell you sal is what he told us
and we were thinking this would be a
great birthday gift for you
is john a light actually signs baseball
bats that he killed people with
you so do you denounce the use of the
bat but then
sell it as memorabilia yeah it sells it
as memorabilia so john a lights
wait who what type of person you have to
be
to buy an autographed john a light bat
i'll be probably worse than the now john
a light himself well he better make sure
someone doesn't take that from him and
beat him with it
beat him with it well yes i mean johnny
li just know that it's
just a portion of the proceeds for the
sale of the bats will be donated to a
youth charity
wow a portion of portions oh a portion
of the
to a huge charity doesn't make it any
better doesn't make it any hey listen a
portion of our peanut butter sales go to
yopeanut.com saratoga peanut butter
so basically john eli and us basically
covering the same ground
same guy they make what they make for
the
ultimate souvenir you can also choose to
have john write a custom message by
choosing the inscription feature
i'd like man i'd like john to write
look john a like this is like oj selling
cop
signing knives that's what that is it's
like oh
shiny coaching john alex custom design
autographed baseball bats are the
ultimate memorabilia
for john a life he has nothing else in
the category
it's just the bad yeah he's that's him
and by the way uh
hopefully he doesn't watch our podcast
oh i think he is john
can you scroll up a little bit is that
these bats have been customized designed
and engraved and then are individually
hand signed by john
they make for the ultimate souvenir for
any johnny light fan
yeah and those who are fascinated about
what the mafia once was
i like that little caveat in there like
also you don't have to be a fan of them
but if you're once fascinated with the
mafia that's what it is you can choose
so this is all at johnnylight.com he
also wrote a book about his time in
prison
and the mob 200 for the side baseball
bat by the way so
so not not too steep of a price and i'm
just putting it out there
i think i think that we should buy a
john a light baseball bat and give it
away to a lucky member of the patreon
when we make one
i uh on the normal circumstances
should we buy johnny life right now with
the company you want to just do it let's
see
let's find the bat what are you saying i
know how do we reward john a light
what do you mean i mean really i mean he
got six people he beat people with the
bat
yeah but he went to prison ford and now
the rest of it goes to a youth charity i
know but he he made a plea deal right
he did make he how was he out of jail if
he killed six people
i think it was a plea yeah i think i
think it was you know yeah you talked to
the feds and
yeah let me ask you a question okay when
when you know when you caught him and
did you catch him in any tender moments
like what's he like like
did you feel like you got a taste a peek
of the real
john a light and and and and then also
how is he functioning
in society now when he's capable of that
like how how i don't even understand
like even motivate who's hiring him
to be a speaker like hey we got someone
that's going to come in here he's going
to knock his socks off with his
motivation
right but asterisk he also killed so
many
so many people yeah uh suspend disbelief
and just listen to
what he has to say now don't look at
john a light and think of how he's
brutally murdering
all those people uh refreshments post uh
yeah he'll knock your socks off with his
words he'll knock your head off
so so he so he has said he said quite
often through the podcast episode that i
did with him on my
at the christy chaos show he said that
he said that
that he now wants to tell kids and let
kids if anyone to get with any mafia
into any mafia organized crime unit
whether it's italian chinese russian
whatever
that it's not cool and that you
shouldn't do it and that eventually
all the guys turn on each other and that
it's it's just not the way to go
for the kids out there who who wake up
and say you know what i'd love to be is
an organized crime
yeah but he does love takashi 69 thank
you almost
he does love takashi 69 right he said is
one of his favorite musical artists
who is a known who is they're coming for
us right now
feds are coming for us the choppers are
here yes i know you heard that but this
chop is circling above
you have on mafia glasses right now i do
i think a little bit right those are
little mafia-ish oh i thought it was
more like uh
i don't know a programmer from 1982. no
but but that that's why they were those
old-school
mafia all right yeah i love the fact of
a guy who's just decades as a mafia man
he's murdered people he told you
murder people and get a cheeseburger but
he's here to tell you today kids
yes not cool now cool and you know what
he's talking about murdering people and
all that stuff but he was always he's
very like politically correct
like um tt jerry who's who's who's a
a character on the christie chaos show
who who we would we will one day
actually be on hey babe we will get tt
jerry
who's someone from my life it's uh my
girlfriend's um transgender uncle
who who was in prison for many years he
will come on we will introduce he was
almost gonna do it with me while you
were away
right and then things felt felt some
stuff fell through his parole officer
basically said he couldn't do it that's
basically what happened
is tt jerry we're working now we're
putting in the proper paperwork we're
putting the proper paperwork
truthfully to get tt jerry on the show
but he tt jerry was also on the upside
with john ayla and he's talking about
killing people johnny and this and that
but he was very respectful of tt was
like you know
how does it feel you know being
transgender he wasn't calling him
any slur slang he was like my
transgender community
and all these things and i was like wow
that's interesting he's got to be he's a
motivational speaker
right so you can't yeah right so you
have to be you know politically correct
wow yeah so it's interesting and i'll
tell you what when he came in
he had a beautiful suit on beautiful
shoes beautiful socks
he smelled amazing he smelled and i
wanted to ask him what
john gotti smelled like but then i
thought i could i might get a baseball
bat
yeah i told you you started asking extra
questions extra questions but
yeah but wait how is he living if he did
a plea deal and got people arrested
because i'm just going by the movies i
don't know do they all we asked the same
question the piper
he asked a question he said he doesn't
he doesn't look over his shoulder
anymore because he said
it's that part of it is kind of all done
he said everybody's became a rat
everybody he goes i would never wear a
wire and i said well you have on a wired
lav mic
and he said only for podcasting i said
okay that's what he thinks
little does he know bring him out bring
him out yeah
so he told us you're untapped
he said to mafi it's changed so much
that he doesn't really have to
worry about it cut to probably today
john allied killed in the streets in
brooklyn
i wonder how he broaches that topic on
like a first date
or when it's getting a little serious
like it's our fourth fifth date we've
seen a couple of movies together right
we've
we've split a couple of checks right
he's liking this new young lady and now
he has to be like
there's something i need to tell you
about my past yes and she's like
let me let me guess you filed for
bankruptcy before and he's like no
and then there's like a criminal but not
that yeah yeah no but really how do you
do that
like and do you do that before you sleep
with someone because if you let them
know that afterward and they're like
i wouldn't have it's a real trick i
don't know what the code of ethics is
there
i would prob me personally like when i
was single
i would always tell a woman that i was
going on a date with hey i have a
daughter
i'm a co-parent so i also so i would
lead with that
that's similar that's so i think that if
i was doing that then i also think if i
also
had said i'm also murdered people i
would put that in the same breath just
because i want them to know what they're
getting into
yeah so i'm a co-parent yeah johnny
likes a murderer similar but different
yeah
listen i just want to let you know
before the apps i have blood on my hands
yes yeah i have blood on my hands
well and he also did tell us on the
podcast and the same thing and i i mean
i didn't correct him but
it only hit me after i said i said in
the beginning of the podcast i said how
you like in brooklyn
there he goes good he goes my girl lives
around here i said oh that's great you
know whatever and then
45 minutes later i said so what's your
relationship status he goes i'm single
so i don't know what happened to his
girlfriend in the 45 minutes on the
podcast he might have got a text update
yeah yeah so so i don't know what
happened but
in the in the midst of the 45 minutes we
had a girlfriend and then we were single
and also
when we first started uh messaging john
eli to to get him
onto the show we were messaging an
assistant by the name of pascual
and then very quickly two weeks later we
got a text from a man named felix who
said i am now
his new manager so we don't know what
happened but squall
12 years old they started committing
murders what were you doing at 12 oh my
god at that point voltron was huge for
me
i was committing sci-fi murders in my
head
because when he said that to me that's
the first thing i thought of i said
south
i don't know if that's when sal said he
committed murder dude 12 or 14. i
couldn't remember
i was always very impressed by 13 i had
my own phone line that i paid for yes
yeah but he had killed so one of his six
body counts was at 12. was it a was it
an adult
wait i thought it was john i thought he
was murdering people for john gotti
who was he murdering his friends he
didn't say that he murdered anyone at
12.
so he was saying he was albanian so
allegedly the italian mafia
used to basically outsource their hits
from the albanian cruise and john was
like we do with tech exactly how we
outsource
right exactly we're not doing the dirty
work here we're outsourcing that
that's what the mafia do they would
outsource to the albanians he actually
gave me his business card
which has his phone number on it in
email and he and the albanian flag
and a picture of him from prison wow
yeah here we go so this is this is his
that's his business card and if you flip
that around it's albanian flick
but what is it a business card for i
don't that's what i wanted to get to
is i didn't feel comfortable asking that
but now that he's not here and i feel
more safe
i i thought it was you know i think he's
still in business
so he says here he's a keynote speaker
and that's the first bullet point which
means that's his most
that's his most prominent title yes so
first and foremost he's now a keynote
speaker he's a keynote which is actually
different than a motivational speaker
yeah like when you give a keynote for
something like steve jobs
yes like what is he given the keynote
for i don't know and then you go to his
website it says page not found
so so his second is movie consultant
that i could certainly see and the third
is actor
and i could see that too a lot of these
guys that were mixed up in crime they
want
authenticity in the movies and they hire
him and they give him stuff
it is insane to me that he is selling a
bat that he autographs that he used to
beat people
with yes oh and the card says mafia
truth
yes by the way shout out he does have a
podcast called mafia truths
um and i believe he has a patreon called
mafia truths and a pun and and is
johnnylight.com he can find out all the
information he actually wants sal
you know i know that he's he's he's had
in his life murdered people and beat
people up but he's actually was a very
pleasant man
to be around he was very kind he was
very kind and and my family was also
there and you know even
you know my family was like we just felt
good around him and i was like yeah
i it was very very very strange feeling
is it again any stat on how long he's
been reformed and or made that deal is
it
are we talking 20 years i think he was
god yeah let's
when did he get out of prison pimp like
what i i don't know
okay 1995 it was arrested for illegal
possession of a firearm
that happens you don't know that you
have to have the license in every state
what can you do
after his release three years later he
earned an additional three months back
at prison for smuggling sperm donation
kits for a fellow inmate who was trying
to impregnate his wife
which is in theory a nice thing to do
yeah i mean what is a a donation kid
anyway
outside of a cup yeah what yeah let's
let's he smuggled in
so okay so he was trying to give life at
this point he's trying to give life
so in other words so really if you count
that one he gave he really only killed
five
exactly because he gave one back yeah
john if you're watching this is all
this is all tongue-in-cheek here buddy i
just really wish you and everything you
do the best
yeah please don't google me and yeah you
know like
i uh i really my job here is to
entertain and if you feel like i haven't
entertained you yes
uh i really apologize and i really want
and no trouble whatsoever
with you and uh you know you know
i don't have much more to say about that
right yeah yes and and um no he was
so he got three months more for
smuggling smuggling
which seems a little ridiculous it's
like why not smuggle so he left prison
and then went back to visit the guy
like because he said he after his
release three years later
he earned an additional three months
back in prison
for smuggling sperm donation kits for a
fellow inmate
which means he was out of prison and
then going back to the prison
to smuggle in a sperm donation right
right
so that also means that that guy had to
produce the sperm
give it back to him so he can get it
back to the lab
right wow right wow so it's kind of like
you go
i just want to let you know sal i would
100 do that for you
you need a sperm kit smuggled right you
talk to me right all right you talk to
me
i would always do that for you okay and
so when you were interviewing him did
your mind
wander to that surreal place where
you're like yes
he might be 20 years away from this but
this man at one point has seen things
that would real that are chilling to me
and and then you got like a little
nervous or was he pleasant the whole
time and you guys
you wouldn't have known otherwise he was
so pleased that we're getting your own
head when he was talking like
he was so pleasant and friendly to me
that i
i didn't know kind of like what was
going on at times in the interview like
i forgot what he even did
and was accused of and i would forget
questions
things to ask him and then homeless pimp
would jump in and just ask him like
homeless pip had really good questions
he asked him like did he ever
get you know did you know because he was
so used to like killing people and hurt
people did they ever have to like [ __ ]
or have diarrhea
or vomit during uh during like a uh
you know a burglary or a murder and he
said yes he go there was sometimes we
were waiting for a guy to beat him with
a bat and i really had to go so i just i
grabbed in the woods
and then we came back he's like can
imagine that he goes i left no
fingerprints but imagine they found my
ship prince
[Laughter]
oh man yeah so it was very that's gotta
be a terrible feeling like you're
outside somebody's window waiting to go
in and your stomach starts rumbling oh
yeah you're like i got to get this over
with i've been there before but we've
all had to pick poops on yeah we've all
we've also had to go to the bathroom
during the murder and uh yeah
you ever talk face-to-face with a
murderer for anybody or or know somebody
who then eventually went on to murder
someone but
hadn't yet then you know i feel like if
i did know that person i'd be able to
call them up in my mind immediately
but nothing comes to mind but i feel
like i've had to know someone who's
murdered someone
yeah even if i didn't realize it i just
mean like well that's [ __ ] it's like a
law of averages if i've met
ten thousand people in my life somebody
has to know something i always think
about that too like with all the people
like say you pass in new york city i've
had to have walked past someone
who later in that daily day who who
later on in that day or within those 24
hours was their last
day on earth they were murdered oh yeah
what a word of a heart attack or
something
like that statistically it's an
impossibility that you haven't
if you grew up in a big city walk past
someone's
last moments on earth
we did a college together years ago
maybe like three years ago you and i
yeah me you and roy wood junior you know
it was in
indiana i'm forgetting the name but i
remember it being in india i remember i
walked out and it was
it was a full auditorium right yeah it
went back yes and it went to the tops
yeah
it was the bleachers yeah i think there
was at least 500 maybe maybe more made a
thousand people there
and i remember right in the front row
dead center was an old married couple
and i came out and i immediately like
like i was just doing a little crowd
work and i said oh
you know you know and they said we've
been married like 50 years they were
getting rebels like oh like
i said who do you think's gonna you know
pass away first and the whole crowd was
like oh
and i was like what's the big deal i
mean you have to think about it right
you know and i was like
what's odds are that someone in this
room is going to die soon like maybe
and i brought up that stat and they just
weren't they just turned on me yeah
they weren't having it that was like
apparently that's not funny to them
because a lot of people don't want to
face the truth
where it's like the the chances are
someone here might die tonight yeah and
there was a couple who was
the first minute i was on stage i was
like look to your left and right
someone's going to die tonight
how many people die every minute you
know like but it's the truth
how many people do die every minute pimp
let's find out how many people die every
minute
death rate is 120 a minute cell wait
for where though for the world
65 million a year die 178 000 a day
7 425 an hour and 120 a minute in the
united states
oh the world i'm sorry the world okay
okay so
wow that's two people a second yeah
forever forever just boom boom boom yeah
since i told you that 11 people have
died
yeah it's crazy let's get a counter up
on the episode just how many people are
dying
just just do it the whole tick yeah look
use it as uplifting because if you last
the whole episode
you made it but you know and you know
sal but it's been
what have we got well what percentage of
americans have murdered someone
uh according to the fbi
that 3.9 per hundred thousand
no more than one percent were done by
syracuse on average there are 25
to 50 serial killers operating in the
united states at any given time
yeah well one of them is doing my
podcast next week his name is john eli
we
interviewed him today and he will be out
next tuesday
uh point zero zero four six percent of
americans were murderers in 2013. which
is not a which is which is i'm happy
with that percentage
what out of a thousand people what is
that
that's two thou that's a hundred a tenth
a hundred
a thousandth of a percentage point so is
that
like it's one out of a thousand
no i think it's one out of divide uh
divide one by a thousand what was that
what does that yield you
one 0.001 right or
uh 0.01 no that's one of a hundred so
one at a thousand would be 0.001 so your
thousands place
thousands so one out of five thousand
or four thousand six hundred yeah yeah
right right right yeah so one out of
four thousand
so so so whatever yank at every sold out
yankee game there's ten killers yeah
yeah well what will reduce capacity not
not to mention murderers row not you're
right
yeah right reduced capacity though they
only have eight thousand so thank god
that's the only positive one we have
killers at least you have less serial
killers in the crowd for yankee games
yeah
that's a positive thing i thought about
everything about killing anybody well i
was going to ask you that this is hot
under the collar maybe you
maybe you reneg it 20 minutes later but
i i think
in my mind i've thought i could you know
i'm so angry at this person i could kill
them
but i don't think i could ever
intentionally follow through on a kill
no never in a million i don't think you
think i could kill an animal i couldn't
kill
even if it was to eat like i couldn't i
wouldn't hunt
i can't i don't know i understand like
hunting's a thing and i
the people that want to do it and love
doing it i understand why you do it i
get it i'm not here to say
to hate on hunting i just don't know i
could ever take a life if anything i
know
it's hypocritical to say because when we
eat meat and chicken we're ju somebody
else is just doing the work
yeah yeah yeah yeah but i but but i i
can't kill you
you have a kill you ever cook a lobster
that was live when you got it home
no but i told you i put the crabs in oh
remember i told you the story where i
put the crabs in
the the my father had me take get crabs
from staten island he told me to put
two knives in them and then rip their
arms off and throw them in the boiling
hot water
yeah absolutely i remember you did that
i thought yeah i did that when i was a
kid it was
very you know i was traumatized yeah i
mean
more than 70 you've killed a lot well i
wouldn't no i can't do it i
i've seen people put him in the pot a
lot i've been i've been there
why do they put them in the pot alive
what's the point i think that's i think
it's actually a quick
death maybe but birth control um
i i think it's a quick death or maybe
like they it's fresher sweeter me i
don't know why they do it
obviously the sooner it's dead before
you're reading it the freshest it is
right
yeah i guess i guess yeah i was with
someone who put the freaking metal
through the
through this through the um lobster and
there was like
i thought they were the lobster was
screaming have you have you heard this
no i was like i was like oh [ __ ] the
lobster screaming i'm freaking out i'm
freaking out and i
don't even need it but apparently it's
like air being released
from its head yeah oh here we go while
lobsters react to sudden stimulus to
twitching their tails
when placed in boiling water the
institute suggests they do not
have complex brains and allow them to
process pain like humans and other
animals do
but we will never know how how do we
know that yeah how do we know how the
lobster feels
yeah i think you know like what about a
bug
yeah does a bug feel pain we've you know
we've talked about it no we haven't
talked about it i've thought about it
and i do think they feel pain but i
don't think
i think like when a bug gets stepped on
it's almost like them being
like evaporated like they don't i think
it must be so quick and powerful that
they probably don't even feel it it's
gotta be it says they don't feel
pain they might feel irritation or can
sense they're damaged
but they cannot suffer because they
don't have emotions
right right how do we know they don't
have emotions how do we know that
i don't think he has emotions that's
crazy so
when they say don't swat at that b
you're going to piss them off you piss
them off that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what else doesn't even
know what pissed off is no you don't
know what pissed off
what about when you hit a wasp's nest
and they're all like oh they're gonna
they're gonna come after you now they're
angry
right they don't have emotions but
according to according to these
scientists
on google they don't know yeah nobody's
really how do they know dogs are
colorblind
what tests are we doing did you know
that no i
so i heard i know that dogs are
colorblind and i know that the
equivalent
of their more birth control yeah the
equivalent of their
noses like how much they can smell
would be if we had their noses it would
be if we could smell something from
from new york city to san francisco
that's crazy talk google it come on good
that
something how could that be possible
dogs 300 million olfactory receptors in
their noses compared to about 6 million
in us
uh and the part of the dog's brain that
is devoted to analyzing smells is 40
times greater than ours dogs have
something called neophilia
which means they are attracted to new
and interesting odors i feel like i have
that
i like a good new smell i got something
for you right here what is that
i can't believe this came up what is it
i got someone brought me this
it's a new sense it's not consent it's
from um
aesop this company fables yeah
exactly oh here it is babe you ready for
this okay
should i close my eyes you don't have to
okay if you
you if you think that closing your eyes
will heighten your old factories yeah
do it oh yeah let's hit that old factory
on the old factory you know the cranial
olfactory is the second cranial nerve
it's an optical fact it goes the way the
acronym is
ooo to touch and feel a girl's vagina
and hymen
let's see how many of these i can get
pimp pull up to 12 cranial nerves please
oh oh oh you're kidding me olfactory
optic oculomotor um
trochlear trigeminal oh this is from
school isn't it yes
to touch uh oh okay
trigeminal to touch oh abducens
yes to touch and feel facial yes to
touch and feel
uh one more um
what's the second a i'll skip it atm
at i'm i'm just forgetting it i'm
forgetting i'll come back i can get this
ooo to touch and feel a girl g
uh glossopharyngeal is that right
gloss glossopharyngeal oh to touch and
feel
a girl's vagina uh vestibular yes no
what
hypoglossal everybody knows that of
course go to touch of girls vagina and
hymen
i'm forgetting the two i'm sorry whose
acronym is this
these are the twelve nerves this isn't
the textbook actually no
the t-shirt didn't tell you to sacrifice
this was taught to me by dr futterman of
n.y.i no
no what a god doctor dr benjamin why
would he throw over to touch your
vagus nerve how could i forget the vegas
the las vegas because what happens in
that nerve stays in that nerve
listen to me accessory nerve i let it i
let us all down i want to know
something though what what what a doctor
was telling you that the acronym to
remember all these like please excuse my
dear aunt sally
was touching girls vaginas that's the
way to that's the to touch a girl's
vagina and hyman
but there was just 2000 he was saying it
to the girls in the class too
yeah but everybody that you know that's
just the way we remembered it but
is the vegas one v-a-g-u-s
does that have to do with vagina is that
why he's saying vagina because it was
inferring the vagina already
or is he just making a funny little quip
of an acronym that was like
what i don't think even fudderman made
it up i think that's a thing amongst
the field is that's the way students
remind remember this 002 touch and
feel a girl's vagina and hymen which
seems outdated and you probably can't do
that
it seems wild yeah google cranial
how to remember the cranial nerves oh my
god more than 700 million
chickens are slaughtered just for super
bowl sunday oh my god
that's more than a cup okay second
largest day for food consumption in
america
oh my god 60 billion chickens
raised each year 60 billion
a year so in the grand scheme of things
i mean john a light hasn't killed as
many people as we've killed chickens
yeah yeah you know we all need to take a
look at ourselves
we all take a look at ourselves you know
i mean if you can eat chicken you can
buy a bat
from johnnylight.com hey magic spoon
i love you order magic spoon please but
here's a tit bite you don't know
i've done 100 magic spoon hands and they
have yet to send me some
spoons send us send sound magic spoon
magic spoon is the best freaking cereal
you've sell i buy it on my own i got
home from los
angeles yesterday for three months there
was a magic spoon waiting for me out the
front door i swear to christ
what by the coke all fruity pebbles are
their new flavor honey grain
did you almost black out when you said
honey grain yeah i saw your eyes flicker
because it's so good
yeah it's so good it's amazing it's got
zero grams it's a cereal
and you eat it and it's healthy yes
right yes
it is you're not going to get a cereal
like this 14 grams of protein you eat
cereal you get a
jack yeah you talk about net carbs how
about
four you eat that four you go right to
the beach
only 104 like only 140 calories a
serving so you could stay that lean mean
skinny [ __ ] that you are well i can't
eat it because it has gluten
no it's gluten free it's got grains
it's got no grass i don't want to eat it
it's got soy
it's got no soil i can't eat it's loaded
with carbs no
yes it is low cost i'm not gonna eat it
what about all the gmo
gmo free well you know what i always
wanted one day i want to be friends with
keto
well you get to be friends with keto
because keto
this this is keto friendly and they got
oh
dude and by the way the cinnamon flavor
the cinnamon flavor here's how good the
cinnamon flavor is yeah is is i
i got me and pimper eating the cinnamon
flavor in los angeles i bought this
stuff
by myself they said buying it i've been
buying it the cinnamon flavor was so
good that i took one bite of it spoonful
i threw it at my
neighbor i hit him right off the head
with the bowl of cereal because it was
so good
magicspoon.com hey babe listen to me i'm
telling you i cannot advocate for a
product more
i love this cereal magicspoon.com hey
babe
if you and then you use the promo code
hey babe you save five dollars off your
first order
fi and this cereal is expensive but it's
so worth it five dollars off your first
order magicspoon.com
hey baby use the promo code hey babe get
five dollars off your first order i
swear to christ this seriously i have
never seen you more passionate
not even about a product about anything
in your life i swear
listen to me mark my words if you are
listening people of the upper government
if you want to have peace in the middle
east
dropbox is a magic spoon on the gaza
script no
problem that's nice i swear to god
brings people together it brings people
together magicspoon.com
hey babe use the promo code hey babe
five dollars off go do it try the
cinnamon cereal
it's amazing also if i'm being honest
the rate for us just doubled magic spoon
there it is
yes it has sal yeah babe you know this
podcast is sponsored by better help
wow it's like you read my mind have you
been talking to a therapist no but i've
been reading the copy on the screen here
because we got a promo to do oh i
thought that you were going to say that
you were talking about therapists that
better help oh no but
i do it's an online counseling thing
where it's it's really all discrete
and you get to match up with someone uh
they assess your needs
and you get a licensed professional
therapist online you could start
communicating within 48 hours let me ask
you this the service is available for
clients worldwide you said today that
you sent david blaine
a twitter message from italy if you
could go back in time would instead
you would would you instead sign on to
betterhelp.com and talk to the therapist
about the message you were about to say
david blaine
well it was 12 11 in the morning and i
was sitting on a terrace alone
i probably needed to speak with someone
other than blaine at that moment and
guess what at 12 11 in the morning
wherever you are
betterhelp.com has a professional for
you that's right they got they have
over 1 million people who have taken
charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional better help want you to
start living a happy life today
and the people that us here at hey babe
would like you to start living a happier
life today i really would and honestly
we
joke we do joke but we're coming out of
a crazy year
and i think a lot of people might be
looking for help and don't know it
or looking for help and don't even know
where to go and we're like
handing you this because we have spoken
to many people
who it has done a great service for so
there you go your special offer for us
yes hey babe listeners right now off
your first month at betterhelp.com
hey babe that's better h-e-l-p
dot-com hey babe 10 off your first month
can't recommend it enough i actually use
it
and it's been great um i don't think
that i think a lot of us don't even
realize
the mental health um that we're under in
today's world and this really just helps
out so if you you know instead of dming
me or sal looking for help and and and
you know
we're not therapists i would go to bed
oh we're okay help we're okay
yeah yes yeah but you need better health
yeah yeah dot com
slash hey babe go do it and um
and yeah and uh 10 off can't put a price
on sanity
so what what what's the smell close your
eyes okay and tell me where you think
you are
just all right so i he he said smell
this it's this new thing i just got he
had
extra samples so i opened it i smelled
it i said wow this smells like
something very familiar and then i
placed it and i was so happy i did a
little like
a little like kick okay okay ready where
are you right now
you smell that you getting it again
smell that right oh am i am i in church
yes you are i'm in church is that
incense
it is it is frankincense frankincense
which not to be confused with
frankenstein that's right i never really
uh
smelled frankincense before and in this
in this thing here is cyprus
vetiver is that i can't read vetiver
maybe
cybers and freaking frankincense
frankincense that's what frankincense
smells like
yeah so that's it smells like church
smells like church
and guess what frankincense one of the
original gifts it was brought by
the wiseman frankincense and myrrh from
impractical joker this is what i'm
telling you
it smells like the day of jesus birth
yes that's what jesus birth smells like
wow dude it smells good it means nailed
it it made me
i know i know i'm talking about old
factories i nailed it i got a good ol
factory and you know who else has a
great old factory and as
is all his cranial nerves are top-notch
is tom brady give a quick shout out
oh because you know what happened they
got they just won the super bowl tom
brady 43 oldest guy in the nfl this guy
oldest guy in the nfl and he won it in
tampa which is the first time that's
happened
not to be reduced though patrick mahomes
great great the kansas city chiefs you
gotta you can't really say
enough about them and you can't really
even say chiefs anymore so let's just
call them the kansas city football team
yeah the kansas city football team
so awesome how about this five
science-backed benefits of frankincense
you ready let's do it as well as seven
myths
let's find out let's play the game
what's a myth what's a fact now you
close your eyes you tell me
i saw the first thing okay it may cause
arthritis
may reduce arthritis oh then i shouldn't
have even looked yeah it may reduce
it i need to i need to try it because i
crack my fingers and knuckles
you might know this as a guy who studied
the body physical therapy yeah shout out
dr fundament
shout out dr flutterman shout out dr
nutterman exactly
shout out another butter shout out
peanut butter shout out peanut butter
and jelly shout out salty sweet
combination
shout out yo peanut.com shout out to
peanut butter go check it out
go to charity go to charity just like
johnny okay yes i crack my
hands and fingers yes 30 times a day
easily
am i going to get authorized is that
like something my mom told me to scare
me
is that an antiquated thing i would say
it's antiquated in a myth a lot of
people get air
in their joints depending on the most
likely place you'll get arthritis is
your knees
right your knee i i crack them all day
long
that that that they'll go like this back
and forth i have a whole routine
yeah i wake up i do it the way the way
that they just cracked when you just
open up your hands with a tiny bit
alarming but not i'm not i'm not
so scared here's what i'm telling you
and i swear to god and i'm telling you
seriously
the way i just cracked it was like five
percent of how they normally crack it
usually sounds like
literally like some like like like like
like
firecrackers right
how about this because because it's such
it's such a good sound good thing
we're only going to crack your knuckles
if you want to hear sal's crack knuckles
patreon.com when we make it
we're making a list make the list sell
all the crackers knuckles on the patreon
the noise of cracking or popping in our
joints is actually
nitrogen bubbles bursting in our
synovial fluid so no of your fluid which
keeps the joints moving
like it's like lube exactly like
lubrication exactly
it's the way your joints get horny and
ready for a night of [ __ ] says dr
clapper
according to dr clapper synovial fluid
lubricates your joints like motor oil in
the car's engine that's what it is
reducing friction and preserving our
cartilage yeah so
is it bad or good no that's what i'm
saying a lot of people say it's actually
at least a physical therapy school they
were saying there's actually benefits to
cracking the knuckles and you should
so it kind of is in a bit an old wives
tale but you don't want to over crack
them and overextend your fingers and
joints because obviously that can cause
issues on the ligaments what's over
cracking babe i would crack them
every time you feel like you
you need to crack them like things
against if i would crack them
okay i would crack them i'd crack your
knee i'd be careful about cracking your
neck
you crack your own neck don't have
somebody else do it unless they're like
obviously a professional
yeah yeah okay can we go back to the
frankincense um myths
and and facts okay go okay yeah
pull up the whole thing what's a myth
what's the fact i want to see how many
sound gets right because he really [ __ ]
the bet on the beatitudes
yeah yeah and don't go anywhere i mean
because we're about to discuss
frankincense facts and myths and that's
why
you guys come back week after week after
week
we should title the episode that it'll
be a real killer it'll be a real a light
this one
here we go you ready yeah close your
eyes frankincense may improve gut and
[ __ ]
gut function is that a fact or is that a
myth okay consuming it or smelling it
can you consume frankincense i'm going
to say fact
fat yes that's the fact the resin
appears particularly effective at
reducing centers of crohn's disease and
ulcerative colitis
oh wow so two major problems two major
major problems
um so they're saying fact improves
asthma
frankincense no false
70 of participants reported improvements
in symptoms such as shortness of breath
and wheezing after receiving 300
milligrams of frankincense three times
daily for six weeks
how do you receive frankincense i don't
know how do you receive 300 milligrams
of frankincense i don't know how to
receive 300 milligrams of frankincense
but i
i i can already tell you this 100 it's
not as good as sunday scaries
go to sundayscaries.com use a promo code
hey babe that's better than frankincense
that's right
um ken here let's let's let's do let's
do one more
and you go back okay frankincense
maintains oral health
what do we think i i'm starting to
realize that frankincense might be
edible then
yes i think people eat it helps maintain
oral health yes in other words it's
going to strengthen my teeth and gums
high school students with gingivitis
chewed a gum containing frankincense
for two weeks both gums were more
effective than a placebo reducing
gingivitis so it reduces gingivitis why
don't why don't we know about all these
facts about frankincense i don't know i
don't know i think it's something with i
would think
big government and big brother trying to
keep frankincense after this episode
so many more people that walk around on
a daily basis are going to know
so much more about frankincense than
they did before they listen to this
podcast
i mean we get hundreds of thousands of
listeners yes right yes think about that
they're all going away now
armed with the frankincense knowledge
and then people talk
right so those couple hundred thousand
people might tell another fifty thousand
people
by the end of this week there's gonna be
a quarter million more people walking
around the world
that have an education on frankincense
that didn't before i'm starting to
realize
i'm starting to really start to think
now this thing fights so much
i think that's what modernist secret is
they're putting frankincense
curing everybody yeah that's what it is
all right scroll down scroll down a
little bit here we go
helps prevent diabetes myth or fact
i i feel like diabetes is such a bad
thing that if
if that helped prevent it i would have
heard it i'm going to say
myth myth is right small studies report
that frankincense my hippo
may help blow her blood sugar levels
however recent high quality studies
found no effect here we go frankincense
needs better pr
i mean apple cider vinegar is doing big
things these days all the stuff with
frankincense
yes i might you you should name
you ever meet someone named frankincense
i met somebody named frank yeah but not
incense
not in sense not frankincense be great
if you knew a guy named
frankincense that just smelled like
frankincense all the time wow do you
think you'd like him or do you think
you think you'd hold it against him if
he smelled like that like would you just
put my nose i think i'd like him because
that
smell that that it smelled like tr it
had it was interesting it was dual thing
it smelled like church but it also
smelled like miami i can't explain it
yeah i know what you like like it
smelled like the delano in miami
yeah the delano or the delano yeah yeah
i like to put it a little accidentally
so u.s social security administration
public data the first name frankincense
was not present it is possible the name
you're searching for is less than five
occurrences per year
so out of 6 million 122
890 records wow
one name was frankincense that means
that there's either zero to five people
so less than five people out of six so
no one's named france you're
listening to the show and you know
someone named frankincense or your name
is frankincense
please write to the show how do they how
do they write to hey babies do we have
an email they can email
they want to ask us questions yeah
yeah we'll pull that up hey baypod at
gmail if your name's frankincense only
we will not open up any emails
from people who don't cannot prove that
the name of frankincense better better
better yet let's do this let's put
frankincense in the subject so we know
who you are
if you if you if you know we know what
you're writing writing about
if you know someone named frankincense
or if you know someone who knows someone
named frank's let's reach out
but also send us what you think the most
unique name you've ever heard is i
met a guy i'd like to know i like to
crowdsource unique names i met a guy
once his name was soberto
like so birdo not roberto his name was
sober roberto
soberto s-o-b-e-r-t-o i was like hey my
name's soberto i said what do you
what do you mean roberto he goes you
know it's soberto
i was like okay i never heard that one
and his nickname is cell
swear to god really just call himself so
yeah my grandpa's birth name was
norberto
are you serious swear to christ are you
serious i'm not joking
apparently it's a cuban name or a
hispanic name nor berto yeah i mean he
went by tony but like
interesting yeah wait a minute what do
you mean he just went by tony his name's
nobody since
he was a kid they didn't call him that
they called him tony i would have called
him bert
yeah it's wild because i didn't find
that out until like i don't know like
maybe
15 years ago right so it's like i didn't
know my grandpa's like
when i wa it was it's weird to know
someone your entire life and then
realize
that their original name was not the
name especially when someone you love
like my grandpa
like a grandpa yeah it's actually a
little like it's it's it's
it it's shocking yeah also i hadn't
heard of the name norberto before that
right how many people named norberto
sunday scariest did you try their ice
cream oh i loaded up on it dude the
sunday scares is fantastic
it's excellent it just calms me down
yeah and then i was just having in the
form of a gun
gummies or oil like how they how i
usually get it from them but then they
recently sent me a cbd ice cream yeah
you believe that no the seat it was
fantastic i'm telling you the sunday's
scaries at first
you know we started reading and
answering like oh we'll do the reads and
then they sent the product that's my
favorite cbd product i've ever taken in
my life
i uh i pop a little bit of sunday
scaries and then i watch game of thrones
and it makes it a little bit more
palatable i'll tell you one thing i
ain't shook in 2021 no more i was shook
in 2021
and i'm not shook at 20 21 no mo you are
because the sunday scares because guess
what if you go to go
on if you go to sunday scariest.com with
the promo code hey babe
you get 25 off that's 25 off at sunday
scariest.com promo code hey babe with
your bad self
did you get a chuck i didn't get chicken
20 21. you didn't get shook in 2021 yet
because you know why because you know
why else and also it could also be a
good thing yeah and also
i and also what's one thing i always
forget what one thing i always forget is
always i'll always
be forgetting to take my vitamins and
the cbd gummies are you
forgetting to take i would take my take
for you don't be gonna take my body i
take my vitamins
every day well the cbd gummies are the
perfect product to help you kick back
and chill the [ __ ] out because they
added vitamins b12 and d3 to get that
extra boost of vitamin goodness in that
ass
to give you the perfect blend to make
you more tolerable to your co-workers
and friends cbd all up in that air all
up in that ass
and if you vegan has a mother like me
they got you too they got vegan gummies
called vegan
yeah yeah guilty with a product it's not
us it ain't us and it's a guilt-free
version of cbd you've been kindly
hunting
yeah to help you forget about becky's
showboat ig account
yes man they get salty up in the center
salty up in here
25 off at sundayscaries.com with promo
code hey babe
there's no better way to go to church
than on a little cbd
but hey fellas we're in the thick of
winter and the storms are brewing it
looks like one to three inches are in
the forecast when you trim that
hibernation bush
that's taking place in your pants
luckily our partners at manscape
specialize in products
to make sure you're walking around town
with beautiful snowballs manscaped is
here to provide
you the best tools for your grooming
experience offering precision engineered
tools
for your family jewels i'll i'll tell
you what the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer i'm
being dead serious
it says the best hygiene tool for the
modern man they're a thousand percent
right i have that lawnmower 3.0
that it's literally to the skin shave i
i no nick nothing it's so my balls right
now look like michael jordan
i'm telling you really yes your balls
look like a six-year-old black man
yes wow the lawn mower 3.0 championship
six rings michael jordan
that's what my balls look like from the
lawn mower three-point 3.0 now let me
dance on that i wonder what happened
to the people who who had the 1.0 on the
2.0 i don't know what happened to them
godspeed
if you have that and you love it you got
to know that the 3.0 is what you got but
even better right yeah they have another
thing called the crop preserver
preserver which is an anti-shaffing ball
deodorant that make your balls smell
nice and make you feel like your testes
are walking in a winter wonderland well
that's always fun i love what it is
all you got gotta do is go to
manscape.com hey babe you're gonna get
20
off plus free shipping that's
manscape.com
hey babe oh look at this unique and the
usual baby names 2019.
girls tally okay kaylani rochella is a
tough one rochelle my name is rocella
yeah that's like rochelle and coachella
yeah trixie bell trixie bell
dre dewey danian
jatimi jatami jatimi is
jatim out of all them i could deal with
jatami
i think roachell is rough rochello no
disrespect if your name's rochella we
appreciate your support
when i was younger i had a babysitter uh
there were two twin girls
and uh they both babysitted me and my
sister roxanne and rochelle
roxanne and rochelle yes did you have
crushes on them uh
i was like i was a little too young for
that but i think at one point i was like
oh these are
girls that wear nail polish and have
breasts and wear like jewelry and stuff
so
yeah god bless them you know but sure
yeah roxanna was a big name when i was
younger
i don't hear it a lot any much longer
but roxanne shantae
you know roxanne roxanna i want to be a
man no uh right she was like uh
in the early hip hip-hop community like
a little pioneer of
of of of him i like the name roxanne i
do too actually i really do like the
name
i actually do too yeah yeah roxanne
nobody's too much roxa i like roxanne
roxanne destefano so that's noberto
german
he was nor berto nor berto almost like
norbert is norbert a name
is that something that eddie murphy did
yeah his name derives from old nor
german nor burst
nor berto so norbert with an o at the
end of it
yeah yeah no berto no nor bit is what
i'm thinking of right
northern means northern brightness okay
northern brightness but it's saying it's
a german name
most things go back to german or latin
names okay
what can you do um so
so you know three months haven't seen
you i gotta be honest
talk to me i got an email i wanted to
show you too okay speaking about
speaking about unique names
it doesn't three months even though we
haven't physically seen each other in
three months i
feel as almost like you haven't moved
and i haven't moved to me
you look like your hair be everything
looks like it is in the exact same
places when i left you yeah i'd
probably longer yeah i haven't moved
since you left
[Laughter]
i just was like all right be back let me
know when you come back yeah i just stay
here
yeah i get brought food and yeah yeah
because i was just one of those
i don't know i just had a moment where i
was like it feels like i never left and
i was wondering maybe sal's
just been sitting there now yeah i just
been doing my thing it feels like you've
been gone
a long time but not yeah like we're
right back in the swing great to have
you back
all this and that but you've been gone a
really really long time i've never
the longest i was ever out of new york
ever for anything before this was two
weeks
now i was gone for three months it was
one of those things where i
didn't you haven't come back once not
one time really not one time
do you feel do you think you feel what
it would feel like if you lived on the
west coast
i do settled in enough for that i do
feel like i embraced it on the west
coast and it's not even
more about like west coast east coast
thing just for me
it very much stamped down that my home
like where i want to be is on is in new
york it is not a disrespectful statement
towards l.a
but because i had because here's the
thing is if i wasn't there with my
family it could be very easily be like
oh i'm missing my family but i had
my girl and two kids you really did get
these i had my family with me you had
your own car
your own home yes you went to work every
day you got in your local spots
yes we were watching the local tv like
everything do you think you'd feel
differently if
we weren't in a state of still shut down
this like or do you think that you got
what la has to offer you got your
sun-kissed skin
you did your thing you ate your burritos
i i i feel like yes i got
la i understand like with things being
shut down whatever but i
you're a new york kid i'm just there
there's a flow to new york
and east coast cities that i can't
explain it's almost like you walk
outside in new york and you're just in a
river and you're flowing in the river
and you just
you're fine new york is finding you
where la i feel like you have to find it
because it's
interesting there's no flow it's like
you walk you walk to it it's like it
they're like beautiful lakes that just
you're there
and you got to know where to go and then
you walk to the thing and then you stop
because there's a freeway there and uh
you know yeah you know there's just you
can't walk anymore where new york is
just like
you just keep finding more things to do
i felt very
isolated and alone in la and i had my
whole family there with me so
it was actually a point it was a thing
was a weird thing that was happening was
like oh i
understand now why some of our friends
who go out there
who are from new york get in really bad
shape get on drugs maybe even some of
them
hurt themselves and in entertainment
because i'm like you really start to
like
the walls close in on you a little bit
at least they did for me i heard there's
like a year
or between a year and two when people
move to another state or that it takes
that long to acclimate and come out on
the other side of it
because like joe joe from my show gatto
moved to la
one time and so did brian quinn and joe
was gonna come home he hated it after
like six months
waited he moved to l.a so west bolton
moved to west hollywood
wow and uh i was like um you should just
you got to give it some more time and
then he gave it like another like six
months or whatever and then
he came out of the other and really
really liked it he just won the black
and white but yeah but he went out there
alone alone himself just him yeah see
that's the thing is as i
i i don't know like that's tough with
the fan i just was like i would
literally
i'm friends like i was watching i was
watching youtube accounts and instagram
accounts that were just about new york i
was watching live streams of people
walking in new york there's this kid on
youtube called action kid i mentioned
mama
i've been mentioning him because i was
literally every day just sit and watch
i would sit and watch his youtube
because all he was doing is walking with
the camera on a book bag through new
york
just talking to people and i was like i
would rather do that
his name is action kid what does he do
he just walks around
he is a patreon too but he is
is it like slice of life is it like is
he interviewing
new yorkers no he just walks through the
neighborhoods is it just like a live
stream
yeah like right now if you just look
we'll yeah go to greenwich villa
where did you even find this child i
just put in youtube i just play on
youtube i miss new york
you put in the youtube i miss new york
action kid came up yeah this kid popped
up
see i watched this exact one and i
started to cry a little oh my god we
walked that street every day it's down
the block from the comedy cellar yeah i
i remember i was watching this exact one
tearing up
wow yeah because i was like oh my god
please make a left please make it left
because i want to see the comments
subway station open right there that
fourth street one right outside the
theater
yeah yeah so yeah watching this from la
and i
was it was a beautiful home beautiful i
meant beautiful people
you know wait i'm sorry what is
happening here
nothing i was just watching it weeping
so it's just
is this a virtual a virtual tour yeah he
just walks around and does this but to
me
for somebody like me this was huge for
me because i was
i was seeing new york oh he gives you
the the street he's gonna walk
yes oh what a unique idea yes so i was
just sitting there watching this and
then yeah
yeah it's like yeah it's like literally
like i was like oh this could be me
and and and you know wait this person is
a youtube millionaire
i don't know if he's a youtube mill is
he yeah yeah he makes yeah
action kid yeah this is what he does how
do you know that how do you know it's
financials
i mean well you just figure it out i
mean it is such a unique idea
especially if you want to like be like
get a taste of what a city might be like
before you go there or something
i do that with all cities like after i
think we talked about this after i
finished um
the show um what's wrong with claire
danes with the terrorists
uh homeland homeland i did well i know
we spoke about this already
i did a whole i watched the whole
youtube video of just a guy walking
around islamabad pakistan
i just want to see what looked like and
it was fantastic so islamabad has their
own action kid islamabad has their own
action go to go to walk around islamabad
islamabad pakistan yeah walk in the
streets of of of uh pakistan or
islamabad yeah
yeah i don't know if it was this guy oh
that's fox news okay
yeah it's different when stuff's cut but
when you're just walking down the street
you really get a sense of it it was very
peaceful to watch it just walk and hear
the sounds and
you know it was it felt like it just so
and then you know
so now i'm happy to be home and um and
uh yeah i don't know and oh and by the
way a little cherry on top at the end
um and this is all true this was this
was filmed by the homeless pimp
the step through the final week of my
stay the final week
of my stay at this house that i've been
there three months
chazz pumeteri sunny from a bronx tale
and his entire family knocked on the
door and stayed at my house for a week
and occupied two of the four bedrooms in
the home
did you not know they were coming we did
not we were we were told we were told
short notice that that that chas and the
family would be coming so we got an air
mattress
and we made it work who who was the air
mattress for
for chaz's children oh wow yes yes
okay yep so we got it because it wasn't
enough but doesn't the fact that you had
to get an air mattress mean that you
didn't have the room for them
well yeah because because we had two
beds we had we had one room that had two
beds which was the kids room my
stepson and my daughter then the room
downstairs was was for the homeless pimp
then we had a bad dream they got to be
older children no
older children yeah okay so so so they
and uh but only his daughter showed up
not his son so we prepared an air
mattress for them in their master
bedroom
um uh but but then she
as soon as homeless pimp left we washed
the sheets quickly and
his daughter went and slept downstairs
because chas has got a big snoring
problem
oh maybe he has maybe a sleep apnea i
asked him he said no way he said they
sculpt me
they wait so it was like it was
basically like a sitcom
it was two crazy families living under
one roof in l.a
for shadow water out of water chaz left
his wallet in an uber
one day so we had to go on a whole
adventure to find his wallet meet the
uber driver
in in reseda california we drove in the
parking lot it was sketchy didn't you
have work
chas needed his wallet so i had to show
up late to the set
oh will you like are you like his his
right hand when he's when you're around
are you like his consigliere i'm chrissy
consigliere okay yes
how did you track down the uber driver
well because chas his wife
uh is access to his uber account so we
figured out where he was
and we uh figured out uh his number
called him and the guy
you know the uber driver was like um uh
you know i have your wife but you got to
meet me i'm working i'm working so you
got to meet me here
and chad's like what if i just pay you
to drive back to me
i'll give you three times your rate he
goes no i can't i'm at work he goes
don't you work driving a [ __ ] uber
he's like just drive the uber to me and
i'll give you a lot of cash
if you make me go meet you i'm not going
to give you anything he's like i'm
working you got to meet me in the
supermarket
so so it was interesting so it was
interesting that then we lost the key to
the house
and it was underneath the car so me chas
chaz's family my entire family
were on our hands and knees looking for
a key while my six-year-old daughter
show uh was shining a light with our
cell phones to try to find it oh in the
evening one night someone dropped
the evening we couldn't find anything it
took us about an hour to find the key we
finally found the key right no way to
get into the house
how did you um how did scheduling go
with two different families
were you operating independently under
the same roof
or was there uh was there a bathroom
schedule that had to be worked out
and also with the normal time that
you're going to bed and waking up if
that didn't sync up
did they watch television in a room was
did someone stay in the living room and
someone retired to bed
was someone up bright and early when
other people were still trying to sleep
take me through the uh the
minute-to-minute semantics of sharing a
home with a full another family
unexpectedly good question so
here's what happened is chas and his
family
came and beautiful people we were very
close with them loved them so much
they they came they came to the house
hour then what happened was is our
schedule me and my family schedule we
more adapted to them because they're fun
and full of life
and we had been there for three months
we kind of needed that zap so what wound
up happening was
is i would go to work and then while i
was at work
chas and and and and his wife giannis
lovely life gianna would take
my family around and do things with them
and when i would get home
i would then join and the only thing
that would happen is i would i would
drive the car
instead of chat so i would drive my
family around with chad's family in the
car
all in one car we fit all in one car we
got an infinity uh xq 80. so
it's got shout out infinity shot at
infinity so it we could
seven people we could fit seven people
so that's just what we had
these seven people when when homeless
pimp wasn't there and where did you go
you were you like a little like a tour
bus where would you go
we drove through the hills we went to
like sightseeing yes like just everyone
looking out of the windows of the car
while you drove yeah well like a
pleasant drive like a pleasant drive
homeless pimpin
and and chas went and found the first
theater that chaz did one man show a
bronx tale at
his old department from la he walked
into his old or he knocked on the
apartment door
of his old apartment where he used to
live and he was like hey it's me and
they're like we don't know who you are
we'll call the police
um you know it was things like that did
you ever do a thing where like
you know you can't be going on tours and
strolls and active
24 7 for that whole week was there a
time where
you just like plopped down on the couch
and you look to the left and it was chas
his wife and you guys both watched like
judge judy together well no we were
plopping down
his ritual at the same time on your
shirt and we'd eat we'd eat
we eat ben and jerry's ice cream or
tiramisu and we watch
f1 drive to survive on netflix about the
grand prix and the and the f1 so you had
like like a little routine together
yeah like you started watching a show
together yes and chaz frequently would
call it one f he would say hey put on
one f on netflix i was like oh f1 he
goes yeah
yeah he was also a chance commentary was
also at my daughter's birthday and he
did
his sixth birthday sixth birthday and he
gave her 200 dollars cash
in her little oh wow wow very chazz yeah
in my head and then
my daughter because she's six tried to
feed it to her american girl doll
so we have to then take the hundred
dollars and then put it in i would have
looked if i was her
how great would have been if she took
the 200s and would just like rip
ripped it right in front of her like i
don't need your money i don't need your
money i got an american girl
yeah yeah yeah so you know what this
gets me right here maybe one outfit for
this thing
yeah have you been to the american girl
doll store oh my god me with a 200 i
can't even buy a goddamn slipper for
this
i literally got hit for three hundred
dollars in about five minutes in america
it just got
hit yeah by the way the psycho's at
america the american girl doll place
yeah i mean i mean
i mean i get it as a kid it's someone
it's a billion dollar idea
oh yeah but basically these poor parents
are bringing their kids
to a blaze basically to hang out with
dolls but then the place
operates like they're real people like
you gotta buy the dollar sandwich isn't
that true 100 like
you eat breakfast with the doll they
bring out food for the doll they do the
doll's hair and stuff you're like paying
for like an extra plus one it's a doll
when we got on the plane yesterday with
my entire family going back
shout out delta i you know you guys it's
great great playing great airplane
airline but it's enough's enough you got
to start serving food now i think
you know i the flight attendants can
walk up and down the aisles
right we need to start serving we need
sustenance we need to start doing this i
can't
i can't survive on the biscotti cookies
right even though they're decent they're
decent but i can't
well we got to start serving food let's
go let's grow up now yeah
let's grow up you remember when food was
just like a coach ticket would get you
like food drinks
everything nothing yeah nothing but i
went to our seats and you know we were
30
30 33 b 32 a 32 b
so i was sitting next to my daughter and
delilah when i was putting the bags up
she had the american girl doll in my
seat i said baby gotta move
the america she goes but this is where
kiara is sitting i said no that's where
daddy's sitting and she was like why
can't you sit there
and there was a seat across the aisle i
said because that's someone else's seat
she's like but they're not sitting there
i said they'll have to move the doll
that's my seat
and she was like i'm not going to move
the doll and i was like
delilah either you move kiara right now
move her and you hold her on the lilac
yeah yeah and you hold her on the lap
or you hold her on the lap or you or i'm
gonna put her
up in the storage bin i'm gonna put her
up in the storage bin
you know um uh above the head she goes
okay fine
gets up takes kiara puts kiara in the
seat across the aisle puts a seat belt
on her
goes sits down looks out the window i
sit down put my seat belt on
jasmine my girl turns around she goes
just don't move if nobody sits there
just let the doll sit there
i said that's not somebody's seat and
she goes
and she goes just let the doll sit there
so literally nobody ever showed up to
that seat the entire flight kiara had
her own team
making jokes she was i was like i was
like hey her tray tables down
i was like somebody i was like i'm not
sure that she put her phone on airplane
mode
has a i said i said to this i said kiara
is a koala bear
is that a pet therapy animal i mean
what's going on but sat there the whole
time and then delilah every time that
seatbelt would get up
gerard would delilah would get and sit
and attend to kiara's needs
took yard to the bathroom ship kiaras to
go to the bathroom i said the seat belt
signs on said but dad she's got to go i
said there's turbulence she said she's
gotta go
she's gotta go who took her to the back
so the people that american girl
you're the the the story that you're
weaving here is just affecting millions
of parents and you need to be stopped
i think you cannot have these children
thinking these these these kids need to
be attended to like actual siblings
yes no i can't and now it's to the point
where my mom got her an american girl
doll
her mom her grandmother got an american
girl doll and when we got home
there were there was an american girl
doll in the house that we already
shipped
so now my daughter thinks any house she
goes to she's going to get a surprise
american girl doll
so also a little antiquated in the fact
that it's just american
and just girls yeah i mean at this point
it should be a global
yeah doll yeah well my daughter when we
went to this point when we were in the
car she said i'm going to make an
american boy doll when i grow up
you're going to have to make it a lot
quicker because that
thing is probably already in progress i
said you're only six years old hun
but but but the american girl doll it
made her happy um
it was great great birthday gift for her
um kiara who's from australia
um you know got a qualifier got a book
bag
i know it's it's a pretty penny right
and the coronavirus
shut down three three american girl
stores wow
american girls stores right i mean no
one is
no one was above no one was above
the risk of the panda even american
girls shut down three stores even
america yeah because they're charging
you money for an
inanimate object because how do you eat
how do you keep the american girl dolls
in the store how do you keep them six
feet apart it's very tough
yeah they're flying off the shelves yeah
what happens to the
all the american girl dolls that that
close down like what do they do with
those is it like when
is it like when like when like the
sonics like the supersonics don't win
the championship
but they printed all the shirts right
and then you see over in like
africa in africa everyone's wearing like
it's just like tons of american girl
dolls over in africa
or maybe they were put up for adoption i
don't know i don't know what happened to
the american girl dolls but also
american girl dolls of course made in
china
um well let me ask you this though can i
ask you this
sure what happened
with david blaine
david do we have time no we don't that's
the end of the show thanks for listening
hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away
from your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey
and it's one of those things where like
my dad like he keeps i keep telling him
like dad like you need to like really
get like your health in order like
you're 73 years old now and he's like
yeah
when i'm walking i feel pain all over my
body i got chest pain i got pain in my
head and i'm like i i honestly sound
like i was a friend like i don't know
what else to tell my dad like what can i
tell my dad to like help him
i feel like it just comes on late uh and
it's quick and
we're never expecting it did you tell
him to uh subscribe to the
hey babe clips page on youtube and to
turn on notifications and then like and
comment
on the page no you might want to do that
it's
if you haven't explored that option and
that's one of those things where like my
doc like his doctor is like oh he's got
all the answers and i'm like did you
even ask him to like and subscribe
and click notifications on the hey babe
clips page like that's barbara leia's
chest pain
yeah i didn't even think of that yeah
well doctors are going to do that right
they're not
a lot of a lot of doctors don't have
really good bedside manner
they're going to tell you what's in the
textbook but they're not going to tell
you about real world stuff well
well i was looking i was looking through
his through his uh through his medicines
the other day
and he didn't even have he didn't even
he wasn't even subscribed to the no
pressure network on youtube watching hey
babe
on thursdays and and and taste buds on
monday i said dad what are mondays for
he said penicillin i said and the buds i
said what are thursdays for
he said my heart medication and the
babes and then once i told him that he
got a little bit better
but i think not subscribing not
subscribing liking and sending
notifications to the hay babes clips
page
could be the difference maker i think
that's why his health's plummeting